yeah I don't say that anymore for
example in my public talks wow but when
they introduce me I say just say Neil
deg Tyson was supposed to be him number
two and he's devolved into some sort of
like halfwoke very confused person uh
here he is on the Wild Ride podcast
explaining a bit more we played One Clip
earlier in the week when he was on with
Bill Maher but he's very confused about
all this gender stuff and well look at
how he's now dealing with his shows if
it's wrong to say ladies and gentlemen
yeah I don't say that anymore for
example in my public talk
wow but when they introduce me I say
just say
humanoids because why specify gender at
all you just all humans who are out
there so say yeah so when I'm introduced
they have explicit instructions to say
instead of ladies and gentlemen which
has a ring to it right a historical sort
of Legacy feel to it it's just please
welcome to the stage Neil degrass Tyson
and anyone who hears that is going to be
human and react and so why specify I
like that man I think that I'm done
saying ladies and gentlemen you want to
give this one another shot no I think
that was fantastic you just retired
ladies and gentlemen yeah yeah I mean
ladies and gentlemen that that is a load
of bunk uh let's be clear nobody's
offended by ladies and Gentlemen even if
they were it's completely ridiculous and
we don't always have to go to the lowest
common denominator again this is sort of
like the previous clip it's not that
it's the biggest thing in the world but
I think that these are like these little
markers in society where we just keep
catering to the crazy class whether it's
the media class who lies about people
doing good things like Mr Beast or the
people that are supposed to be our
intellects who our intellectuals who are
just constantly degrading everything uh
Ian ladies and gentlemen offensive not
offensive can you tell me offensive so I
guess so but I think what's what's
scariest for me is the people of science
are the ones diving head first into this
it's one thing to have you know weirdo
academics on college campuses screaming
various things about gender but when
supposed Authorities on science and
biology is part of science you know the
idea that there is sex and it is
different is part of science when these
people are diving head first that's
really scary it's like mathematicians
out there it's like Steven Hawking
announcing that 2 plus two is five
that's the same kind of level of what
we're talking here it shows how really
Insidious gender theory has become and
you've got so many people like Neil
degrass Tyson who had really care more
about their popularity and more their
attention than basic truth and so
they'll quite happily throw science
their supposed love into the shredder
just to protect their own skin I think
that's really showing how powerful
gender theor has become CJ I have a
theory that young people actually want
older people to tell them the truth they
actually don't want this pandering
nonsense anymore I think it explains a
lot of Jordan Peterson's success and
many other people that they can't make
sense of the world because the people
before them that are supposed to hand
them something have decided to shred it
up does does that resonate with you yeah
I think it's definitely true and once
people realize that they've been lied to
for a long time that turns into anger
because who wants to be lied to and I
think what's really interesting to see
here which is why I talk to you know
often times I get conservative parents
who will reach out to me on Instagram or
Twitter and they say you know how can I
prepare my kid to go to college I'm like
well it's biblical right you got to
train up your child in the way which
they should go so they they won't depart
from it the problem that we have
sometimes as conservatives is that we're
so worried about liberal indoctrination
that we kind of are like oh let's not
indoctrinate our kids ourselves before
they go to college and it's like okay
you don't have to indoctrinate them but
give them a found found so when they go
to their college campus and they listen
to their leftist Professor trying to
cancel ladies and gentlemen and say that
there areund genders or that gender is a
social construct they can rely back on
those teachings that you gave them as a
child and say this isn't correct this
isn't truthful this is wrong and that
they will have the courage and
conviction to sit there and raise their
hand and say I disagree because courage
is contagious you know they're often
times when I was at you know in school
and I went to the University of Alabama
which isn't definitely not as progress
aggressive as you know UC Berkeley but
sometimes I would be the only person in
the class who would raise my hand and
say that's just not correct that's your
emotion you're trying to pass it off as
truth let's leave this alone um but you
know particularly in this clip I think
Ian hit it on the head it's it's
particularly troubling when you have
people of science you know pushing these
farce of an idea but also too remember
when a PhD like used to be a flex like
you would respect people who had them
because they were like intellectual
people now it's like the last people
that I ever want to speak to it's like
these people are so just drunk off of
their own so-called intellect and and
and just just Cosmopolitan you know
ambition to just cater to every single
crazy phenomenon these days that they've
lost their intellectual integrity and
it's uh it's sad because as you said you
know Neil degrass I assume pretty smart
guy um you watch that clip and you have
doubts about that
though and